[Applaudissements]
une haie d'honneur des applaudissements
pour la première patiente au monde à
recevoir le vaccin américano-allemand
files ventech à 90 ans margrit kiener
est certainement la grand mère la plus
célèbre aujourd'hui au royaume uni
je pensais que c'était une blague dit
elle pour tout vous dire je n'y croyais
pas je suis heureuse de l'avoir reçue et
j'espère que d'autres suivront l'exemple
le personnel de santé a également été
vaccinées à portsmouth
microchip ce fait partie aussi de la
première cohorte de britanniques à
recevoir le vaccin
cet ancien combattant de la marine
anglaise aura passé trois ans dans un
sous-marin à combattre les japonais à 99
ans il fait face à un autre ennemi cette
fois invisible et sournois le
coronavirus j'ai hâte de passer plus de
temps avec mes petits enfants dit il
et mes arrières petits enfants je suis
privilégié ajoutent ils stop ou encore
je lui ai de ministres et la première
dose de vaccin dit elle c'est un vrai
privilège
les journaux parlent carrément de vie
des jours de vaccins ou victoire faisant
référence à la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
fermons devoir en sept journées deux
victoires titre le sun c'est un vaccin
dans le bras de toute la nation dit
boris johnson
non on ne peut pas se permettre un
relâchement
car la grande bretagne est le pays le
plus touché par la pandémie en europe
avec 61 mille morts ça va prendre des
semaines voire des mois dit il avant de
tout terminer il faudra faire preuve de
patience
chaque patient recevra deux doses le
pays compte vacciner 20 millions de
personnes sur une population de plus de
60 millions et pour les indécis
we did nous n'avons pas tourné les coins
ronds rassure le pdg de pfizer
nous avons testé ce vaccin de la même
manière que les autres
alors que les premiers vaccins sont
administrés au pays le journal
britannique de l'insee publie les
résultats d'un autre vaccin développé
par l'université d'oxford affirmant
qu'il reste du travail à faire pour
rendre le vaccin à 90% efficace il ne
faut pas le voir comme une compétition
dit y est nous avons besoin de
travailler ensemble
la grande bretagne a acheté beaucoup de
vaccins mais si d'autres pays avec peu
de moyens y arrive pas ça nous affectera
tous au total londres c'est assurer
l'accès à plus de 300 millions de doses
auprès de sept fabricants la priorité
est donnée aux personnes vulnérables
dont font partie la reine et le prince
philip
ici à tvoï den acker guise radio canada
montréal